.
AND THAT'S THE ANGLE.
JOINING US NOW IS NEWT GINGRICH
FORMER SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE AND
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR.
NEWT, HAS THERE EVER BEEN A LESS
CONS KEN SCHALL PRESIDENT
LEADING A MORE IN AMERICAN
HISTORY.
>> I DON'T THINK THERE'S EVER
BEEN IN ALL OF AMERICAN HISTORY
ANYONE WHO, IN TWO OR THREE
WEEKS, HAS DONE THE AMOUNT OF
DAMAGE THAT JOE BIDEN HAS DONE.
THIS IS AN ASTONISHING
PERFORMANCE.
I DON'T THINK YOU AND I COULD
HAVE IMAGINED IT.
HERE'S A GUY WHO GOES IN, TAKES
A TOTALLY WINNABLE POSITION,
THROWS IT AWAY.
POSITIONS THE AMERICANS SO THEY
CAN'T DEFEND THEMSELVES.
THEN DECIDES THAT HE REALLY HAS
TO OWE OUR ENEMIES, PEOPLE HE
FOUGHT FOR 20 YEARS, THEY'RE NOW
OUR ALLIES OVERNIGHT, SO HE HAS
TO DO WHAT THEY TELL HIM TO DO.
THEY INSTRUCT HIM WHEN TO LEAVE.
AND THEY INSTRUCT HIM, BY THE
WAY, WHILE KEEPING $85 BILLION
OF AMERICAN EQUIPMENT.
THIS WHOLE THING IS SENDING
SIGNALS AROUND THE ENTIRE PLANET
THAT BIDEN IS HOPELESS, THAT THE
UNITED STATES IS OUT OF THE
GAME.
AND IT'S DANGEROUS, BECAUSE YOU
CAN IMAGINE CHINA MAKING A GRAB
AT TAYWAN.
YOU CAN IMAGINE THE NORTH KOREAN
DICTATORSHIP DECIDING TO DO
SOMETHING.
THE IRANIANS HAVE INDICATED THEY
WANT TO DO WAR GAMES IN THE GULF
WITH BOTH CHINA AND RUSSIA,
WHICH WOULD BE VERY DANGEROUS
FOR US.
ALL THESE THINGS ARE GOING ON.
YOU COULD ALSO IMAGINE PUTIN
DECIDING TO DO SOMETHING VERY
AGGRESSIVE IN UKRAINE.
THIS IS NOT JUST A 1-OFF BRIEF
MOMENT IN HISTORY.
THIS IS A MAN WHO HAS BROKEN A
SENSE OF RESPECT, A SENSE OF
RELIABILITY, WHICH WE BUILT FROM
PEARL HARBOR DAY ON ON
DECEMBER 7, 1941.
SO WE'VE HAD THAT ENTIRE PERIOD
WHERE THE WORLD CAME TO BELIEVE
THE UNITED STATES KEPT ITS WORD,
THE UNITED STATES WAS POWERFUL,
THE UNITED STATES HAD TO BE
FEARED.
AND NOW WE'RE BEING LED BY
SOMEBODY WHO LOOKS LIKE A
TOTALLY SCARED BUNNY RABBIT IN
DANGER OF FALLING ASLEEP.
AND HIS PERFORMANCE AT DOVER.
>> LAURA: DESPICABLE.
>> THE MOST DISRESPECTFUL.
YOU KNOW, WHEN GOLD STAR
FAMILIES ATTACK THE PRESIDENT,
YOU KNOW SOMETHING'S REALLY
SICK.
.
>> LAURA: YEAH, IT WASN'T
POLITICAL.
>> NO.
>> LAURA: IT WAS HEART FELT.
IT WAS COMMON SENSE AND IT WAS
HEART FELT.
AND WE'RE GOING TO SHARE ANOTHER
STORY TONIGHT OF A MOM WHO'S
GRIEVING AFTER JOE BIDEN'S
INCOMPETENCE LAST WEEK.
BUT, NEWT, I WANT TO PLAY THIS
FOR YOU, BECAUSE TOTALLY
UNTETHERED TO REALITY JOE BIDEN
WANTS PEOPLE TO BELIEVE THAT
WE'RE ACTUALLY SAFER BECAUSE OF
HIS INCOMPETENCE.
>> IF YOU CLOSE 20 YEARS OF WAR
AND STRIFE AND PAIN AND
SACRIFICE, IT'S TIME TO LOOK TO
THE FUTURE, NOT THE PAST.
THE FUTURE THAT'S SAFER.
THE FUTURE THAT'S MORE SECURE.
.
>> LAURA: NEWT, DID THIS
CATASTROPHIC MANAGEMENT OF THIS
PULLOUT MAKE US POSITIONED TO BE
SAFER IN THE FUTURE?
>> I DON'T THINK ANYBODY ON THE
PLANET, EXCEPT HARD LINE LEFT
WING DEMOCRATS, BELIEVES THAT.
THE FACT IS, THE WAY THIS
HAPPENED MAKES AMERICA MUCH MORE
AT RISK.
YOU HAVE AN OPEN SOUTHERN
BORDER.
YOU HAVE AT LEAST 5,000
TERRORISTS WHO HAVE BEEN
RELEASED FROM PRISON FROM
BAGRAM.
YOU HAVE ALL SORTS OF PEOPLE
FLOWING THROUGH NATIONAL
BORDERS.
THE EUROPEANS ARE BRACED FOR A
HUGE WAVE OF PEOPLE COMING IN.
THEY DON'T KNOW HOW MANY WILL BE
TERRORISTS.
IF YOU'RE A TERRORIST, THIS IS
THE GREATEST VICTORY IN THE
LANDING WAR WITH THE WEST THAT
YOU'VE HE SEEN IN THE LAST 50 OR
60 YEARS.
EVERY YOUNG TERRORIST ON THE
PLANET IS GOING TO THINK, LET'S
GET OUT THERE AND KILL SOMEBODY,
LET'S GET OUT THERE AND DESTROY
SOMETHING.
AND I, FRANKLY, WORRY ABOUT 9/11
FROM THAT PERSPECTIVE.
THESE GUYS AREN'T GOING TO SIT
AROUND AND DO NOTHING.
YOU KNOW, THEY'RE NOT GOING TO
SAY, I'M REALLY GLAD THE
AMERICANS LEFT, NOW I THINK I'LL
BE CALM AND PEACEFUL.
THEY'RE GOING TO TAKE ALL THAT
EQUIPMENT AND SEND IT ALL OVER
THE PLANET.
>> LAURA: IT'S ALL DISABLED
NEWT.
THEY CAN'T USE IT AT ALL, IT'S
ALL DISABLED.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE LED -- I DON'T
BELIEVE ANYTHING THE BIDEN TEAM
IS TELLING US ABOUT VETTING
REFUGEES, ABOUT THE DISABLED
EQUIPMENT, ABOUT THE COLLATERAL
DAMAGE OF KILLING ALL THESE KIDS
WITH THE DRONES.
I DON'T BELIEVE ANY OF THIS
UNTIL IT'S VERIFIED.
NEWT WE HAVE TO ROLL, WE HAVE TO
GET TO YOUR FRIEND.
>> NO ADMINISTRATION IN AMERICAN
HISTORY HAS LIED AS BLATANTLY.
>> LAURA: RIGHT.
>> AS OPENLY AS THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION, AND THAT'S WHERE
YOU START.
IF YOU DON'T UNDERSTAND, THEY
LIE TO Y